foreign
comes from Jonathan in Kansas we have
some money that we are waiting to invest
in silver or gold
some people are saying that the
centralized banking may fall apart and
gold might actually become the standard
again what do you think of that I think
some people spend too much time on the
internet
Lincoln said that it's every uh oh my
gosh every conspiracy theory in the
world no but seriously though it
is always there though like gold is all
it's
been a fear type of idea
you need to get it because of the fear
of everything is going to crash yeah and
let's let's address two different
subjects here okay one is we have some
money we're waiting to invest in gold or
silver okay first we'll address that one
okay never invest in gold or silver
okay the way you pick an investment
as you look at the track record of the
rate of return of the investment
so if you're going to buy a house
for investment
and the area around the house is
blighted crime ridden
full of trash and the values are going
down because the neighborhood sucks
that's the track record of the
neighborhood Common Sense would tell you
don't buy a house there
right
you look and see are the homes well kept
or are the cars up on blocks
you know you look and see you know is
every other house foreclosed on on the
street and boarded up and codes and rat
infested you don't buy on that street
you look at the track record you look at
the track record of a mutual fund it's
been open 30 years it's averaged 12.2
percent that's a good track record right
but I I look at a I look at the track
record of cryptocurrency full of fraud
sucks most everybody lost everything you
look at the track record of Bernie
Madoff really bad idea everybody lost
all of their money you've got conned you
look at the track record of gold for the
last 60 years it has averaged around two
percent a year
that sucks
it's not magic because it's gold
it's a it's an investment
silver the same way horrible rates of
return over a lifespan of investing yeah
there's been little blips based on fear
or greed but gold sucks
as an investment well what if the
Central Bank the central bank's not
coming back you conspiracy bozos
it's a central bank collapses in America
you need bullets you don't need gold
because all hell is going to break loose
I'm gonna say bottled water bottled
water and bullets and I'll take your
bottled water if I've got bullets
unbelievable I mean it's going to be
Anarchy right it's a central bank
collapses every business that you can
name right now that you're familiar with
will have gone away simultaneously
I mean it's similar to a nuclear winter
right okay you're going to have a whole
new government
you're going to have a whole reset of
the property rights and economy this is
not like gold is going to help you in
that no it's not so the central bank is
not going to collapse oh my God
just because one bunch of duber venture
capitalists and startup Tech Guys ran
their little San Francisco Bank into the
bay does not mean the central bank is in
trouble
because it's not boys and girls it's not
so two things don't get into conspiracy
theories because it leads you into
stupid butt Investments like gold you
you can get into them but just oh you
can't get into it listen and be
entertained but don't make your
financial decisions based on them okay
okay but these were all about decisions
these are all about financials that's
right we don't want to do financially
for those of you that are new to the
show Rachel is our resident conspiracy
theory Queen
she believes things that most not that
humans don't believe but she loves to
see what I said two or three years ago
is no fact so I'm just telling you well
you know when it comes to coveted
conspiracy theories they've also no it's
not just that it's
a bunch of other stuff yeah a bunch of
other stuff okay there we go we could
have a whole show Dave let us have a
podcast please we have been people have
been begging for yeah as long as you
don't hear it on this show you can have
a podcast you go do your own little
podcast and you can do that over there
in the corner I don't We're not gonna do
that to this show this show Works
hey hey all of you that want Rachel to
do it it's all the Stranger Things by
Rachel
no weird stuff by Rachel
conspiracy theories by Rachel and have
George on because Jordan they'll listen
raise your hands God there's a bunch of
weird people no it's because some of it
is
true
it is it's true it is area 51. now this
is so great
that's like welcome to Thanksgiving at
the Rams season it's a triple eight
eight two five five two two five